vous savez vous parler de maladie mais
il n’y a pas que ça vous savez ce qu'ils
font les rats ils ont des puces des
puces de rat c'est dramatiques c'est à
dire quand il meurent la puce à vache
chez un enfant qui joue dans un jardin
on s'amuse des enfants il s'amuse dans
un jardin avec des rats etc même des des
gens quand ils meurent leur a il faut
que la température la puce elle se
transmis directement à l'homme ça amène
des maladies très graves on va revenir
comme en 1300 la peste noire le typhus
vous voulez quoi qu'ils attendent car à
virus qui vient exceptionnel qui mais il
faut s'adapter à un moment donné et je
veux et j'en veux pas aux éboueurs c'est
pas leur faute à la limite les éboueurs
c'est leur métier donc ils font grève
mais c'est dramatique mais vous vous
rendez compte vous leur donnez un repas
gratuit mais j'ai pas par 100 000 déjà
vous leur permettez de bien se nourrir
de proliférer et de sortir donc il faut
vous dire quand ils sortent comme vous
dites les urines qu'il achent les tous
les tout ce qu'ils peuvent emmener comme
comme virus comme maladie c'est grave
mais si ça prolifère comme ça
vous rendez compte on est on est on est
envahi